so these these girls we've established
like just how much money is spent in
these host clubs like
how how do these clients have these this
much money because like as we as we've
established not everyone is like old you
know mature yeah successful
businesswoman how
how do these like women in their early
20s like spend like stupid amounts of
money so this comes back to the
discussion about the demographic of the
host club so most of them are in the
nightlife and nightlife in japan pays a
lot yeah like substantial amounts so
they have a huge amount of disposable
income or such expenditures and that's
what they decide to spend it on i mean
like every week it seems like
ex-celebrity is caught in a yeah yeah or
a girl's bar so i mean clearly uh no
shortage of clientele and given the
frequency of these girls bars i mean
they're everywhere yeah no doubt that uh
yeah they're not struggling no it seems
like you know everyone pays each other
like back right it's it's the same
artist like you're spending the 50
dollars around right right it's just
like yeah there's a lot of money but i'm
gonna be paying that money back to you
oh it's it's you okay now now it's your
turn to pay me
i think like a cool like experiment
would be like if you leave like a little
mark on like a thousand yeah
and see if it eventually comes back into
your hand right like that that could be
kind of a good one yeah i'm sure it
happens
yeah [ __ ] but the core of the business
does lie in that though right it's that
the knife life people support each other
right right so do you have time to spend
the money that you earn or does it just
go back into the industry not for sure
bro because and as i was mentioning i
don't do this full-time like i never did
it full-time i mean talking about like
hosts in general yeah like full-time
hosts like do they have enough time to
like spend it on themselves or look like
just
if if you're at like the you know top
one percent percentile kind of thing
yeah
you barely have time to sleep honestly
yeah right yeah so they they just get
like no days off right somebody spend it
on themselves i had a few benders with
the number one guy back in the day and
like his day would go like this
you know i would see him at the host
club after his like hair makeup and you
know he would do his own makeup in the
bathroom i'll call him like all the
names i can while he's doing his wake up
and then you know once the night starts
i see him bringing out all his girls
until like midnight and then from there
he would take me to the subsidiary bar
where we drink for like three four hours
and then we would meet up with another
separate group of girls
that are just like the late night crew
you know after like 3 4 a.m that just
want to hang out until like 10 a.m you
know all right and then we just go hard
until that and then this guy would not
sleep and go for a lunch
okay with another you know girl he's
already like seeing yeah yeah and he
would have a lunch with her and
sometimes go to disneyland and [ __ ]
without sleeping bro how does this man
not not look like a human rat bro like
bro
that's skinnier [ __ ] dude i do that for
one night bro and i look like i've been
hit by a car yeah i look dreadful yeah
it's difficult stuff man so he goes to
sleep at like
3 4 p.m wakes up in two three hours
you know same thing again gets your hair
done get your makeup while i'm laughing
at him you know same thing over and over
jesus
so like i guess from what it sounds like
the lifespan of the host can't be that
long normally surely depends on how you
conduct yourself yeah well so well if
you're in that side if you're in that
cycle
of course
but this is where you know rorando
really comes in strong because this he
is known to never drink
oh he has the helpers with him all the
time yeah and like he's the [ __ ]
definition of you know to become a host
you don't have to drink yeah all you
have to have is good conversational
skills and the people who come to the
club only have to come just because they
want to chat with you right and they
want to gain something out of it right
right so become like a life coach almost
why is it that they have to buy drinks
to like pay the hosts can can you not
just like [ __ ] just give them money
i think it's because if you give someone
money you're way less likely to like
give someone money if you're buying
drinks it's like feeding it's a gift for
you
and and you know you both win you're
getting the drink you want it's like
buying rounds at a pub yeah if i give
you a tenner i'm like expect photography
for an hour gone i'm going to be like
[ __ ] i'm looking at the clock every 10
minutes but if you finish your drink i'm
like you want another drink on yeah yeah
i mean it's i think it's because that
atmosphere just wouldn't get as much
money
is that a spot on analysis my friend
okay there you go
no because like i i maybe compare this
to you know
like going to a strip club or something
and buying a dance that is like money
being exchanged
right and that's i mean i'm sure because
like i think it's the same thing right
like i guess for a lot of girls like
getting to talk to a person is like
paying for a service right yeah kind of
similar to like at a strip club for
example when you're hanging out with
your friends right yeah if you want to
keep hanging out what do you do
buy another drink right yeah buy a round
yeah another drink exactly so so how
much how much are these drinks marked up
like like
we're going into something like yikes
territory how much are these drinks
marked up everything is about like times
10 the price i saw strong zero like the
dead ass bring out the can yeah and
charge you 30 bucks for it yeah as i
said times 10 of their original price
that's what time that's like times 30.
and that was that was chaser that was
like their water the strong zero which
is like a nine percent drink they drank
as like a chaser oh my god it was like
oh that drink was so strong i'm gonna
drink some water oh it's strong zero
yeah because the one thing i always like
know about like the host thing is like
the the donkey tower yeah yeah the
champagne towels
like how many of those did you have to
do or was that just like
okay
because i always thought like
how many birthdays you go
how much how much is it for one because
is it like one is it just one bottle of
dom perignon that you had just before or
it's like multiple bottles multiple
bottles depending on the tower that you
do so multiple bottles of don perignon
which are marked up ten times the price
was it like ten thousand i mean like how
much for one for at your at the club you
worked at
when you got a champagne tower how much
would a girl have to spend if i was a
girl and i want to buy you a dom pen
perrion champagne tower how much would i
have to spend so again this kind of
requires some explaining because
if you're stingy as [ __ ] and you want to
build like the you know smallest tower
you can
but again it's just different levels
like yes
how many glasses like exactly it's all
about you know like showcasing yeah
right the more glasses of tower you have
the more glamorous it looks yeah so even
if you're building half of it with cheap
alcohol in the other half with actual
premium alcohol yeah as soon as it looks
big enough yeah it does the job huh
right so even if it's someone who has
like a you know like only like two three
patrons who's only willing to shout out
total maximum maybe like 10k us for your
birthday
totally 10k oh only get the [ __ ] out of
the club
your money isn't wanted here
we're just talking about like 40
commission of people earning like over
50k so that's per birthday yeah come on
imagine the glamorous [ __ ] so what's
towers that day
what's the most one yeah yeah what's the
most expensive one you've ever received
or something or seasons or scenes or
something what's the most you've seen
someone spend on one night bro like this
is i will be proud to tell the story
till the day i die but my number one
homie yeah he
on this one day
his 30th birthday yeah he racked over
200k us
in [ __ ]
what did you do on your 30th
oh where's my 200k
know what i'm doing
i just i just hung out with the boys
they bought me a [ __ ] drink it cost
like a [ __ ] tenner okay could have
got 200 [ __ ] okay what's going on oh
joey's expectations
yeah right finally an upside to turning
30. what the [ __ ] i'm like 200k so
that's 200k is 40 right so you go you
you get to get like not mean
yeah yeah yeah exactly
and you know chris
when you're reaching that level um of
course you can still have champagne
towers that like surround itself yeah
because the trick is to just make it
three-dimensional so you feel more space
yeah you know um but
you want to be more glamorous when
you're hostile so we hired like a you
know ross royce at the entrance of the
club we have like [ __ ] firework kind
of stance at the end saying she like
make it look like a
wedding celebrity you literally got
pyrotechnics when going into the club
bro it was so much fun though you know
exactly
that sounds like the beginning of like a
wwe or something
from the rolls royce
but but the saddest saddest thing is
well the hostel can only go on a date
and come to the venue in a roll stores
with only one girl
oh my god so you better pick well so the
thing is the thing is when you're the
number one that means you have host
buddies or i mean sorry the ladies that
are saving up for your occasion for like
months all right you know like very sad
dude like after this day you know for
like the next two three weeks it's all
about the conversations like oh i saved
up for like eight months and i still
couldn't get the position you know
it's like oh my god
i guess i guess that makes sense why the
host club you went to was just like
everyone was depressed maybe it was
right before right after a book yeah
exactly everyone's choosing the
possibilities
all the girls are like ah i was i was
eighth in line finally an enemy that can
rival v tubers
who words more
you know you think these rainbow
superchats are like impressive like
beat your heart out